now Andy Murray will be hoping to get
the better of Federer today but how
close is he to February comes to another
very important metric and that's
earnings power and a very good morning
to what a wonderful day it is honor on
this men's semi-final day there's a bit
of a gulf between Federer and Murray
when it comes to earnings this is prize
money plaque endorsements according to a
Forbes estimate in August Federer's top
of the pile 56 million dollars followed
by Nadal 44 million Djokovic is said
Murray languishes in seventh with
earnings of 19 million dollars to many
that might be a surprise Ana because
when he won Wimbledon in 2013 some said
his earnings power could rise to the
tune of 75 billion dollars his
management company 77 says he's turned
down multi million dollars worth of
endorsements if it interferes with his
play with his practice and if he doesn't
believe in the product he will not
endorse it
what's interesting Ana is what he does
with his money he invests in property
here investment property in the United
States he bought a hotel outside
Dunblane in his hometown which he's
turned into a luxury venue probably the
most interesting factors he's on the
advisory board of Cedars the
crowdfunding site he's invested in two
companies one a health drinks maker on
the advice of his nutritionist the plan
is to invest in 40 companies over the
next five years sport tech is his thing
he wants to invest in companies he's
actually interested in by the way the
brand's he's associated with the Under
Armour head and Standard Life the
Scottish insurer Anna a mark you're
standing there in the beautiful sunshine
it looks like outside the or LinkedIn
Club which counts of course the Duchess
of Cambridge the former Bank of England
governor Mervyn King among its members
sounds pretty exclusive I'm sure they
allow you in mark how difficult is it to
join this club now and let's put it this
way you and I the best way of becoming a
member of the All England Club is to win
Wimbledon yes if you win the women's
singles
and I win the men's signals at only
seven games of tennis we become honorary
members if we don't achieve that feat
there's a small chance we can become
members there are 565 members
375 lifetime full-time members 120
temporary members and 70 on remembers
like the duchess of cambridge and like
me or you anna when we win those
Wimbledon singles titles to become a
member you have to be supported seconded
proposed by four members who have to
write a letter in acknowledgement of
your character the committee then
considers your membership by the way
Anna there's no definitive time on how
long your wait on the waiting list
essentially you have to wait until a
current member dies the privileges are
good though a guaranteed seat on a on
center court access to tickets and of
course access to the most wonderful
grass court club in the world
37 pristine grass courts which of course
attended to buy 20 groundsmen just seven
matches Anna for you on I to win to
become a member of the ordering link
club easy peasy